pals gun bros that a yes welcome back to
the greatest game of all time front flap
yeah that's our ass tabletop
yeah oh hey that dumb one hurt ah what
the [ __ ] is going on here New York oh
it's a club alright blend in with my BMX
hey [ __ ] no cash no ass no money no
honey no touching no poontang no coin no
they just get the hell out of here and
come back when you got some money they
just push me on my bike collect all five
coins what [ __ ] coins why do I need
coins
oh there's coin I'm fine oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god yeah back flap
just need more coins
hey kid I only have 15 seconds there it
is VIP B up p1 ahead to the VIP room yes
[Music]
Wow babes butts and boobs boobs
dammit god dammit we need to do more
quest to see more boobs best game ever
alright then let's move on to the next
level Last Vegas baby
Wow never been to Las Vegas but wow it
looks sexy look at them titties [ __ ] oh
all right in the [ __ ] oh wow
remix game one more hey I got a chip hey
how's it going again oh no I'm just
bouncing no big grind across the giant
inflated show girl's boobs
now there's a quiz today I don't know
how to get up there but let's try it oh
god I only have 50 seconds how the [ __ ]
am I supposed to do with that in
everything right we need to get on this
Oh God
yeah that went well oh my god what the
[ __ ] is happening how do i grind titties
I don't understand oh here it is here
this we could do it just grind them
titties
alright alright no no we missed a taste
ah man come on come on come on I'm balls
what are you doing
stop stop stop please please for the
love of God stop I'm awesome please stop
please stop
I never asked for this we can still do
it
we can still do it oh my grind those
titties if it's last thing I'll ever do
coming for your titties they're coming
for you I'm gonna grind you I've got a
brand new titties yeah ah sweet grindy
okay
yeah we did it
oh they became a jump oh man it backflip
a spliff oh oh I'm gonna jump to today's
jump to today's backflip city's Hey what
don't say something
all right see hillbillies beautiful that
jerk he ain't all my shrimp cocktails at
the buffet I hope he pukes he gets dizzy
real easy I bet you did some crazy air
tricks
he would get all dizzy blow chunks
everywhere use a big booby jump over
there yeah we do pew pew you do realize
you're standing in the middle of that
race feel all right cold all right turn
it back around when life turns you back
you have to go black
[Music]
good some bad we did that
hooby backflip oh come on
[ __ ] sake
damn it I missed what the [ __ ] I landed
in the cleavage
yes yes
[Music]
it's in BMX no no